Aloha, I'm Will Revek.
Today we'd like to share with you the many ways
that we benefit from using our oral wellness blend ourselves.
But before we get into the various ways
you can use the blend to navigate to greater oral health,
let's cover some basics.
First off, we've been through many names for our product.
If you've purchased from us in the past,
you probably know our product as the brushing blend.
However, we feel the name brushing blend
limits some of the important ways our blend can be used
to help create a healthier mouth.
So we've changed the name to the oral wellness
healthy mouth blend.
We feel the name the healthy mouth blend
best describes why we make the product
to help people in creating healthier mouths.
We get a giggle from folks calling to order saying,
I want to order more of that tooth oil stuff.
So whatever you want to call our blend,
know that it's the same awesome formula
you've grown to appreciate the benefits
of using in your own mouth.
Next, if you're new to using our products,
let's quickly cover how to get the drops out of the bottle.
The way to get the healthy mouth blend onto your toothbrush
is to fully invert the bottle and count to three.
One, two, and the drops will begin to flow.
If counting to three feels like too long to wait,
seriously, you may want to check in on your stress levels
and take a deep breath while you're at it.
Okay, onto the many ways to use the healthy mouth blend.
Of course, you can use it on a toothbrush
either as a standalone product
or with your favorite paste or tooth powder.
Generally, two to three drops on a moistened toothbrush
will serve as an excellent way
to deliver the potent anti-microbials
in the healthy mouth blend along and under the gum line.
While you can use the healthy mouth blend with any toothbrush,
the benefits are even greater when combined
with a bass toothbrush and the bass brushing technique
described in other videos over on oral wellness.com.
Another way to use the healthy mouth blend is to put a drop
into a bit of water and use that as a mouthwash.
The benefits of using the healthy mouth blend
as a mouthwash is to support all the areas in the mouth
that normally don't get exposed
to the organic plant botanicals while brushing.
And it's also a very fast way as a mouth freshener,
as a mouth wake up call and just bring greater freshness
if you need to have your fresh breath right now.
The next and perhaps most powerful way to use
the healthy mouth blend is to put a drop on your floss.
If you have active gum disease,
this technique is the most powerful way to deliver
the full strength anti-microbial oils
into the gum pockets around your molars.
So here's how you do it.
Simply put a drop on your finger, set the bottle down,
quickly, it's easier when you're in a bathroom
and then place your floss on the drip
and run your fingers along the floss.
This way you're impregnating the floss
with the potent plant organic botanicals in the blend
and now you floss as normal.
You see gum disease most commonly gets going
between the molars first,
which happens to be the most difficult place
to disrupt and disorganize the bad bugs with brushing.
So by first putting a drop on the floss
and spreading along the floss and flossing with it,
you're getting the oils of the healthy mouth blend
deeper into the gum pockets and between the molars
at the same time and full strength.
Very potent combination.
If you want to make drastic positive changes
to your oral health, we highly encourage you
to make this flossing technique a habit.
Another excellent strategy is to massage any areas
of concern for you with a drop on your finger.
Again, this chance to put the full strength drop
of the blend on a challenged area
can help you get heading in the right direction.
Some thrilled customers have reported back to us
that using this technique is knocked down abscesses
along the gum line.
So these are the ways we use and benefit
from the oral wellness healthy mouth blend in our own lives.
If you and your family have discovered another beneficial way
to use the blend to create positive change
in your oral health, please share it with us
by leaving a comment below this video or blog post
so we can all benefit from your experience.
We feel so blessed to bring you this formula
and truly so honored to serve you all,
our community, with our experience,
our knowledge and our research.
Thanks for watching.
Please share this video with others who you feel
would benefit from knowing about empowering solutions,
how to create positive changes in one's own oral health.
As always, hold it with any questions.
We're here to help.
Thank you and Aloha.